welcome to this video this is a new
tactics trainer video from Jessica let's
see what happens yeah you know I'm
already on five minutes something but it
wasn't cheating Aurelia just got a phone
call
just let started the whole thing so um
let's look what happened to him it's a
it's actually the again one of those
underrated session where I just have set
the technics trainer to give me problems
of a certain rating level this is
actually 2,400 level however I recently
learned that there is some inflation in
them so that means that a problem of
2,400 is not really related to 2,400 elo
rating for example there was one
statement that a good Grandmaster should
have a tech to exchanger rating or 3,000
so there is some inflation as it is in
some other systems for example if you go
on the ICC and you do regular blitz
there are people with 3,500 and of
course this is not relating to normal
either rating so this means if I have
this on 2400 it is probably on a
somewhat lower level may be good for
2,000 players or something but it's
tricky how to how to assess those but at
least this kind of attached figure gives
you some idea if I do something like
1800 is much easier than 2400 okay but
let's have a look at this position um we
we see a great attacking position you
have wide of this name he's gotten yeah
he's got all pieces in the attacker
we've got this huge diagonal b2 to g7 I
cannot paint here unfortunately well I'm
in the middle of the of the whole thing
a great diagonal the G file is opened
the bishop is on f7 or psi in the attack
and I'm pretty sure there is some
sacrifice coming some sacrifice
is coming let's start with with
something spectacular the first thing
that came to my mind is Queen to xe5
yeah Queen takes e5 de5 Bishop e5
threatening Luke takes g7 with a with a
great attack but I think black has queen
c6 check which kind of spoils the fun
queenie 5 DD 5 there should be five
queen c6 check and he is also attacking
the bishop that's not good White has to
play with g2 and then the look is in the
pin you cannot even take on g7 after
that however what about rook takes g7
yeah I think this is the right one if we
take on g7 with the rook rook g7 King g7
look g1 check then King f6 we have Queen
h4 check and wins yeah that's a win King
f5 there is a maid somewhere right I
don't see it at the moment the precise
mate but there is made I don't need to
check that King f5 there isn't checkmate
somewhere and King h6 is Queen h4 mate
yeah so Luke g7 King g7 group g1 check
King h6 Queen h4 mate and the big deal
is Ruchi 17 to 7 Luke g1 check King h8
and this is a very typical mate King h8
we have community XD 5 d 5b should be 5
f6 Bishop f6 rook f6 root g8 mate yeah
this is the the main line and this is
winning Luke g7 I mean it came in Oh
King h8 but anyway we want so I have
that so we will just do that and the
check um brief just briefly it's their
queen e5 or something now
my level of g1 is the winning is winning
no no we used to do anything else and
now Queen e5 yeah this is this is cute
this should be 5 f6 take him and route
g8 minute yeah that's cute yeah quite
nice why does it give me problem rating
2003 I have said it on 2400 actually
what is happening here okay I'm doing
next problem maybe there is a there is
some glitch there let's see okay it is
like to move in this position really a
bit cute let's let me check is it Oh for
some I didn't save it I'm sorry about
that I wanted to to do 2400 so 2500 or
something it does not matter and save
settings yeah sorry about that
save settings and it start again okay so
now we have yet another position so the
position before got lost the first one
was cute yeah with all those sacrifices
it was on a lower level though than what
I had originally wanted to do okay oh
that looks really overwhelming for white
right but why does a piece down we we
have a piece down but he black eeeh is a
huge in a huge number of pins with
Knight f6 on 97 this is this kind of
this kind of business still not quite
understanding what the big issue is 97
just looks like a clean win
why is 97 not working I don't see it if
we look at this 97 as my first candidate
was 97 Bishop d7 is losing due to
basically our moves Knight f6 will win
Bishop f6 will also win 97 97 gives away
the queen 97 27 96 check also wins
so 97 Bishop takes d5 I guess but then
rook takes d5 just leaves black in a
deadly pin what is the big problem here
hmm
97 Bishop g4 that nautical f6 check
right I don't see it
Weiss 97 not winning I'm just going to
do it and rook d5 I mean of course and
black is in a deadly pin on f6 yes that
was that was kind of simple um yeah I'll
just take a queen right yeah not quite
sure why this is rated so it was a
pretty pretty simple affair just taking
everything in a way okay the next one
let's see what is the comp doing in
Knight to d7 huh yeah well here we're
dealing with a very strong upon the a
pawn is very close to promotion the only
pieces that that stopping it is the
Queen at the moment
yeah I see some ideas that look very
promising but I'm not sure if they
actually win like a queen a one as an
idea just just to a one threatening a
eight Queen a one Queen a one Queen a
eight and then a move like Bishop
divorce is quite quite strong definitely
but is it winning we should before
attacking the rook black has to take on
the 494 the rook is attacked probably
would be seven and then Knight to c6
something like that looks really really
strong but is it the best continuation I
actually doubt that but what about what
about Queen to d5 isn't this a simple
win 25 and tending eight Queen he has to
take it on d5 I guess 85 Luque to only
move and then rook b1 intending rook b8
yeah that's winning yeah there is
nothing that black can do against that
let us recheck that Queen d5 we just
need to check mostly for move that fight
for the a H square to those forcing
moves that threaten a8 Queen at twenty
five is one of them Queen d5 he really
has to take yeah there is no way around
that
yeah takes it takes d5 rook a to it's
the only move Bishop Knight b6 we just
hack off and then we promote so look at
to then look b1 intending book b8 check
yeah black cannot avoid the check and we
will get to the 8th ranked winning at
least a piece or 25 win takes takes rook
a to rupee one
yep and would be eight is coming no way
to prevent it so the next one let's see
we are playing white and black has just
taken here on D for funny situation yeah
it looks it looks weird because black
really has very little squares for his
King there might be some
meet somewhere see three it would be
check made almost see three is almost
made
hmm this protis also always the
possibility of a pond breakthrough for
the C pawn because the pawn on c5 it is
already rather close to promotion and it
might be the case that we can simply
promote promote the pawn let me let me
check it huh that that that is very very
close to working things like b5 or C 3
check King cakes and then going for the
pawn promotion hmm but how exactly if we
go C 3 check King takes B 5 if black
takes on B 5 C 6 will win because Bishop
c5 Knight e4 is an easy win so C 3 takes
B 5 Bishop takes e5 I guess is more
critical check on e4 King D 4 takes on
c6 Bishop d6 mmm I'm not seeing win
there if we go C 3 check King takes and
95 check that's not really threatening
anything okay takes c3 takes b5 Bishop
c5
and if we then just I will just take we
just take on c6 that's much stronger c3
check King takes c3 b5 Bishop takes e5
and then takes on on c6 of if Bishop b6
there's Knight d5 check winning the
bishop and Bishop c5 does not Eve or
check and then King before night c5 King
takes to Sam yeah that's winning okay so
c3 b5 yeah here I just have forgotten
that okay there was this ramp Bishop d6
and ninety-four winning okay I'm still
still another try
yeah here that's Knight e4 check and
then c7 and we promote right oh no this
is incorrect don't give me that nonsense
this is winning as well last night is
seven
I was stupid is dead I I was I was just
sloppy yeah yeah very sloppy
yeah of course
I actually got it I just I just moved it
too quickly c7 is of course much more
precise let put up the analysis board
yeah let's have a look I was just I was
just too quickly down
Knight e4 check and then c7 I was only
thinking that if we look at this King
moves somewhere and I didn't really
think I was a 97 coming and he protects
c8 and of course I need to reverse those
moves I have to start with this because
after 96 I have 94 and I will ensure
promotion or there is Knight is 795
ensuring promotion I just I just move
this too quickly and white gets white
gets them and gets the Queen yeah so I
got that one almost right almost right
just being too quick on the on the third
move of the whole thing okay let's do
let's do the next one and see what
happens here okay
oh wow we are black here
that's a fairly dramatic situation and
there are various ideas here I'm seeing
some made ideas form for both sides
almost here yeah what black would love
to do is something like Bishop to f1 and
look h3 made yeah this kind of thing the
the second thing that black is going for
miss them is the the D pawn let's think
of and this is probably the more
important issue actually there's also
the knight on f7 there isn't a somewhat
critical state it is always relying on
the rook protecting it from c7 so what
is there to calculate yeah stuff like
Bishop everyone comes into consideration
but there is simply no maid yeah y can
always escape why a g5 to f6 yeah and if
he gets in like King g5 King f6 rook c8
made it will be very embarrassing it's
almost a made on CA them so what is
actually winning here hmm interesting
if we if we just push the pawn yeah well
d3 what is White's replying if we play
that d3 see now he has to play for some
some counter-attack young otherwise I'm
just I'm just promoting the thing like
in tier 3 d3 king g5 d - king f6 and
queens is win because rook c8 I still
have bishop yet so that's not not a big
deal
d3 yeah he can never go to d7 which is
quite quite important because the bishop
on b5 is protecting it so what is
actually the problem of the whole the
whole thing it is is it kind of
Perpetual thing like d3 95 d 296 check
96 check King 897 is a perpetual after
Knight is six check though I can go to
g8 and I'm not quite
9050 396 King g8 check on g7 King h8 and
then rook moved with the tempo is very
embarrassing like rook b7 threatening
mate hmm not good
that's not good at all
hmm quite interesting a 95 is a real
area counter plane huh how do we do that
is it maybe an idea that would be very
elaborate stuff like h6 here just
threatening Bishop everyone and giving
away the pawn that looks and looks far
too complicated if we go D 3 D 395
there's some way to to protect that that
is also h7 hanging hmm maybe d3 is not
not right at all it's them something
else
are there other candidate moves yeah
there is this period especially h3 but
the skin g5 being a being a problem
but they don't want dad
I'm unsure that's not g5 is some serious
counterclaim
do you 395 there any any way to prevent
this counter play again the d2 takes on
e6 King g8 Rob g7 shaking a jade and
then there's this bloody root move but I
can just go back to a area covering the
thing I can just go back to a age and he
cannot prevent the promotion so is this
the win actually d3 95-96 check King g8
giving checks on c8 is not leading to
any right yeah no and the whole thing
with the g7 shaking edge 8 rock back it
does not matter where the rook is going
I'm just going back to a 8 covering the
maid and then I will promote yeah I
guess that wins am I come on I guess
that wins I mean I don't want to take
ages
I didn't it didn't even consider this
reply that is always funny
if you don't even think about it um yeah
well d2 I guess I mean I want to Queen
yeah come on the 2d - must be right here
right okay and now is it mattering much
not really I can I can go to e7
I don't really don't really get it much
if we let's look at the analysis board
for a moment I want to want to just
check one thing so it was this and then
this movie I was I was far more afraid
of night g5d 296 check this is a
perpetual check in a way I mean I cannot
avoid it and I have to here go in the
corner and this was irritating me really
because I feel thinking at first that
this thing is a problem with the made on
g8 ib8
yeah and I have I simply have that to
cover the eighth-ranked and then promote
he has no way to stop the pawn and he is
also out of threads I mean something
like this is is really um it's really
just one check yeah that I mean I don't
think it was that easy I mean it was
irritating at least for me to have this
counter-attacking
idea maybe it is some people easier
because they just pushed the pawn and
don't think about the counter play but I
still was worried okay let's - let's do
the next one
okay that looks somewhat tricky but
isn't this like a black does not have
many moves here in this position the
king the King has very little space and
at first I'm thinking Bishop a5 check b6
Rock b6 and resins where's the problem
black has no moves really Bishop check
be six rupees six and we we are
threatening rook takes be a double check
disaster made everything everything at
the same time now come on
are you kidding this is winning like
just like that huh why is this serrated
so high I don't really know this is like
this is relatively easy you know rook
takes b8 double check mate disaster and
I mean this also rook is six everything
threaten and this is rupees six Bishop
d6 27 we don't really need to put up in
an end as a sport for that so why this
was this was rather easy let's do the
next one
oh this like he has some has sacrificed
a piece to open up the King position
yeah this kind of thing I must admit I'm
not Taurus Lee bad at because I tend to
overlook very simple things that that
are possible let's think about this for
a moment there is this check on edge
form very obvious yeah check on edge
form kingi to Bishop g4 is easy let's
say we give the check he has to go to d2
and what then how do we win if we give
the check on f2 then the King has no
square C has to interpose something
Knight takes there's Knight f3 mate
sorry let's let's do this again check on
h4 King de to Queen f2 check
Knight G to E - that's not every check
let's see - E - I mean besides looking
really ridiculous and as bishop be fire
with mate
okay so Queen e2 is probably and the
move to check how do we win after that
okay there's at least Queen d4 check
that will win kingi 193 check and the
King has to run into the default after
which I have huge discoveries yeah
that's the wind come on that's not be
too sophisticated about it
Queen f2 check yeah as mentioned the the
pieces interposing our mates so I mean
the minor pieces are so Queen Queen here
and I was thinking that at least 20
fights at least a win maybe I have
something better night c4 for example
night c4 Knight c4 King to d1 is there
something winning immediately there
don't see it I don't see anything there
when Queen d4 check was my initial idea
kingi one and then 93 check and the King
has to step if he goes to D - I have
Knight f4 check winning the Queen and
King d1 I have discoveries I mean at
least night F to double check winning
the rook okay that's a win so the Chuck
here yeah okay so I will take the Queen
yeah this was a pretty straightforward
thing let's look at look at the analysis
spot however quickly the check here on
edge for King - D - yeah King he - we
had just Bishop takes that was easy
so King D to the check one stuff like
that we have an immediate made or here
we had Bishop before these kind of
things here there was this made quite
nice and all our mates different and
here I wasn't sure in not c4 it's not so
convincing probably but this is simple
and good after King D - we win the Queen
and King d1 we have at least this double
check winning the rook in the car
maybe there is something better I'm not
sure night f-for check this king that's
Queen d2 we can also take I this is our
also good of course check and then I
mean c3 hang soon
yeah the multiple wins maybe maybe this
is this is the most precise and now
taking or what I mean we win everything
here okay and that was nice let's do the
next one
okay why to play and win hmm that looks
a lot like there is some smoke that made
him why is 95 winning I mean this is
like the most obvious move ever
and it also threatens I mean Knight f7
is also threatening the winner of the
rook so what exactly is the point
hmm
I don't really see it 1995 what is the
point
a 25 maybe 25
huh is it queen d5 Knight f7 shaking
Jade
yeah maybe yeah 9525
oh it's this really a problem I know we
can take on d5 of course yeah
because rook takes rook f8 mate and
Knight takes Knight f7 so 25 is not
defending her that was silly and other
moves to interpose yeah that's not have
seven I mean not g5 just wins what is it
what is the big deal yeah the Queen
takes yeah this is Queen takes and we
just win this this rupee on d8 wasn't it
wasn't that difficult I don't know
sometimes it's weird how those problems
are rated okay
maybe next time I should go to 3,000 or
something to get some some super tough
stuff okay let's do one more
that looks dangerous here
what how do we get in 96 checkmate yeah
this is what we want
96 mate would be really really nice and
there is there is also this idea with
Bishop h6 mate
sometimes hmm yeah the first move that
I'm thinking of course is Knight 2 H ATM
intending Knight g6 mate yeah what is
she doing against that actually there's
also this threat involved with winning
the Queen so if he plays let's say rook
e8 2 2 to d8 or something knight c6 will
win the Queen yeah come on Knight h8 n
that's it what what is there there's I
want me a check on g3 which I will take
with the pawn and yeah that's winning
yeah or this kind of desperado
Knight age eight nine to six major it's
I mean it's funny because we move
through the night in the corner but if
it wins it wins ya know no matter what
so I'm just just funny okay the next
problem
please that looks it looks kind of weird
that looks like a totally random
position hey no way what is this
actually from a material point of view
we are one immune the exchange up Oh
what is this
what is the problem in this position to
be honest ok ok ok if I go let's say
Queen g5 there is Bishop c1 yeah and my
queen is strapped ok and queen f4
there are also some weird Queen trap
Queen f4 maybe this is I mean it looks
totally ridiculous this position but
maybe that truly it's really not so easy
or is it just Queen f4 I mean Queen g5
Bishop c1 it's like that's really easy
right I only have III Queen is without
any squares III Bishop III is it just
gone so I probably have to go to a forum
or is there some counter checking idea
or some direct direct tactic like Knight
takes d4 is not really threatening or
something like that I don't think so I
have to go to a forum and then for me to
e5 Queen F form it's of course also
threatening the rook I have to do that
right there is no other
again 25 Bishop c1 so probably just 25
or is them let's first check yeah and
that is that is that is the solution
right
but 25 and let's just think about it
Queeny 5 Bishop b2 I'm still a little
bit worried about age 6 at the end
Queeny 5b should be to check on f5 or we
go to e6 we go to e6 yeah and the tech a
check age 3 again yeah that's a win
that's when yeah damn it's just not not
step to the mind the Queen g5 because
Bishop c1 it's sometimes not so easy to
to see those kind of retreating moves
that detects something so that was not
difficult but still it's it's good to
see okay let's do another one
and this let this be the final one okay
look to the eighth I want to meet the
guy Queen takes Queen d8 I'm sorry look
d8 mate is the the mating idea so what
exactly is not working with Queen c3
Queen C 3 is just winning right if he
takes it rook the 8th mate the queen is
hanging and after Queen C 395 I can take
the knight Queen takes rook the a this
FloorMate
and d5 rook the ADA's also made so
Quincy three wins Sam come on let's do
this quickly here and then finish things
yeah and here's the maid yep yeah let's
do I did this in 47 seconds average time
was 48 seconds so at least I did a quick
one if at the end
so a nice nice tactic yeah and I also
now understand those ratings better if
this is all very much inflated then then
it meets that 2400 is a level that that
I just set here that Jung is probably
good for for keeping players of mm never
technically sharp and I think this is
okay I mean people with that level
should solve those exercises so I pretty
much have to step this this rating level
up a notch if I really want to very
difficult things like I should probably
do do one where I'm putting stuff like
with 3000 on the board if you really
want to under tough challenge am yeah
okay I hope you enjoyed it anyway
thanks for watching